oh
dude what are you pink in here maybe
it's maybelline
hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we are doing another blind camera
comparison with the new z-fold four the
iphone 13 pro max and the s22 ultra now
the reason why we call this an unbiased
comparison is because max went out and
he took all three phones and he took a
bunch of photos and he set them all up
inside this project and we have no idea
which phone took which one so go ahead
and get a piece of paper and a pen or
your phone
play along with us and let us know what
you get down in the comments let's go
ahead and jump in i'm excited to hear
your guys's opinions well the one on the
left looks really nice really natural
the other two look very similar well i
think i'm gonna go with the right
because i feel like it's the best
balance of all of them it doesn't have
this blown out sky and i also like like
the t-shirt texture you can see it's
kind of detailed too so all right and
all right i got this
the z fold good start pretty good uh the
samsung s22 did not get chosen yet but
here is our next image
i mean i've gotta go with the left man
it just pops out like these little trees
or whatever
looks really nice
that one is wow another one for the
z-fold
uh the one thing is it doesn't have that
macro mode uh which the other two have
but obviously it looks worse you'd
rather not have that's the macro mode
and here we have
a portrait shot of this sign
wow i'm so impressed you go yeah you you
do it the one on the right you're gonna
go for the right terrible
what happened i like the middle it is so
clean there's a lot of like weird uh
haze whatever here yeah it's not that
sharp and it's kind of
flat
another z one for the z fold for me
that's impressive all right and we have
a portrait shot right here with the long
lens immediately i like the one on the
left i'm going with the center no i
think it looks like very natural i feel
like the one on the right like the skin
tones are kind of off oh i got that i
got an s22 s22 interesting nice here we
have a portrait shot but with some crazy
tough objects indoors all right this is
tough but i think i'm gonna go with the
one on the very right because i feel
like it's more moody and if you look at
the glow of the bulbs it has like a
really natural
glow and color as well very sharp i'm
actually gonna go with the center the
center and the right are both really
nice but something about the right one
seems a little too over sharpened or a
little too fake well the middle one
looks really natural so nobody likes the
left one no it's too bright i think is
it also blue it is it is blue yeah oh
all right
good job
samsung did great uh iphone not so much
here we have a food shot i'm sorry if
i'm making you guys hungry yeah i think
i'm hungry i'm getting hungry now again
oh my goodness the one on the left looks
so nice like that little cinnamon
whatever that is it is like perfectly
sharp and i like the colors too it's a
little bit more look how like glossy
that looks
[Music]
good and this i think the other two are
kind of cool like the place blue you
know
z
another one for the scene
that's really good uh in our hands-on i
was very impressed with it and with the
cameras i mean so far it's doing good
let's see if it gets worse and we have
our first selfie very tough lighting
situation as you guys can see i've gotta
go with the left i mean if you look at
the texture of the face is the sharpest
it's not flat like the other two are
kind of like faded i like how natural
their faces look on the right but
everything is really flat while this is
so dimensional so i'm going with the
left
and right that's my first one so the z
fold you have three different selfie
cameras you can use this one was the 10
megapixel front one on this display and
it cannot keep up with hdr here we have
a portrait shot super tough because you
have all that webbing the one on the
right looks really nice i feel like i'm
seeing a lot of detail and the colors
are really natural where he looks kind
of more gray on the other ones i think i
have to agree because on the right he's
by far like the sharpest in terms of
detail and the colors really pop so both
for right and i'll say i was just
shocked by how well this did a year ago
these would have had issues
z fold again
oh my goodness for some reason
i thought this was the iphone just
because you know the colors here are
both more similar than this that looks a
lot different than the other samsung
so here we have a landscape shot all
right so instantly the one on the right
gets cancelled it's way too soft between
the left and the center it is pretty
pretty tough but i feel like i'm going
to go with the left because the one in
the center is like way over sharp
hdr really crazy yeah it kind of looks
like it has more detail but then when
you look closer it actually doesn't
whereas this one the nordstrom is almost
gone
all right
and that is our original shot so the z
fold could do a 50 megapixel mode uh
compared to s22 which is 108 108 that's
why and the iphone's only 12. so the
iphone suck definitely get more
resolution there uh but s22 is king
now here we have a telephoto shot this
is the three times the one on the right
by far it has the best balance of
shadows face uh sharpness everything
yeah these first two there's really not
much detail in them this one's super
flat
s22
yeah that looks natural all the detail
almost like a dslr shot where the iphone
looks bad iphone's getting killed i know
i'm not looking at your numbers yet i
almost looked but i don't think the
iphone's doing great so here we have a
shot of our courthouse i think i'm going
with the middle like if you look really
close you can see look you can see all
the texture look at all these like
shingles or whatever the bricks you
could actually see where here you can't
center it there you go so s22 ten times
telephoto amazing
z-fold is only three times just like the
iphone but it definitely looks better
colors too all right we got a portrait
shot here i think i'm gonna go with the
center because it has the best balance
of the colors and she stands out from
the background where's the one on the
right like she kind of blends in oh true
the one on the left like the skin and
the face is kind of like weird-ish yeah
yeah i think they're all really good but
i think i agree with you i'm going with
the center yeah this looks like a
balance between these two yeah
z-fold
again yeah i don't think it did anywhere
near this good in our last year's
comparison i think it got really healed
yeah the z3 was not good and i did
update all of these to the latest
software too all right well
what is that ultralight i like the one
on the left the most it looks natural
you can see a lot of the details in the
shadows we're here you can't oh yeah i'm
gonna go with the right because uh if
you look at her face and hair it's the
sharpest and uh it looks kind of more
natural uh where the the shadows are
pretty dark which i think it's like
pitch black down there almost so you're
gonna go with the raptor right nobody
wants the middle shot oh i don't blame
you
and
we got
two winners for the z-fold and s-23 just
kill it off
great man all right apple needs the
iphone 14.
we're getting close i know some people
complain like hey uh you know why are
you guys making this give me a new phone
there is but this is what's currently
out
and here we have an ultra wide shot very
tough lighting
i mean i just love the one on the left
it is just so sharp a lot more detail
yeah it's not like blown out as much you
see the detail in the rocks in the
waterfall in the that brick building i
like the colors more on these two but
the detail difference is pretty massive
two for the left and we have an iphone
iphone hey guys we're now surprised when
iphone
that means it's been getting destroyed
so far
well ew what what is that
that does not look like a real that's
not me that's not my claim
all right this is pink i'm choosing the
right let's just get this one over with
yeah all right you guys don't want some
extra detail oh what's up there can we
hear that
i'm not trying to filter on no filters
zero filters like a noise and whatever
yeah literally everything is bad except
for your face yeah maybe i could copy
the the face and like move it right here
what happened whoa this is the iphone
that is the iphone
how did what did it do it's reaching its
limits man
it's reaching its limits i took that
photo twice because i thought it was a
dud
uh
this is a crazy situation the samsung
decided to go for the face and said who
cares about everything else the iphone
tried to get all of it but it couldn't
the z fold destroyed because it has that
mode where you can use the rear camera
that's what it is as yourself that's
what it is and when you do that that
sensor is way better than these tiny
front-facing sensors so this is
something you cannot do on these other
phones and still see yourself so
incredible we have a porsche shot here
mixed lighting the one on the left looks
so weird there's so much blurriness here
and then it's so sharp right there it's
like a sudden
yeah just a massive amount of blur weird
i'm going with the right i think it is
the most natural it has like the nice
depth of field that rolls further into
the distance
we got one for the iphone so
the s22 is what messed up the
that's weird i don't even see this one
i'm taking the pictures on the phones uh
here the z-fold did better that's
interesting whoa
wow
so what did the sky look like was it
blue was it gray i don't think it was
like that i don't think it was like the
one in the middle okay okay i'm gonna go
with the one on the left because i
really love the sunset yeah yeah the old
globe
on like this left side everywhere the uh
oh my goodness that looks awesome it
just like glows yeah this is more flat
and then the sky is brighter too left
z-fold for
doing killing it i gotta be honest i
didn't think it was gonna do anywhere
near the squeal all right we got a
selfie here oh that's so interesting how
the center one the whole background is
blurry and on the right everything is
like in focus i'm gonna go with the
center because the one on the right i
don't really like how that looks um
kind of like dark doesn't really look
natural but the one on the left look at
all the anti-aliasing in the strands of
hair oh yeah yeah i like the blur in the
center one but i like everything else
about the right i'm gonna go with the
right one yeah you guys voted i like the
different colors in the face and the
base looks really natural really nice oh
my god interesting iphone i guess that
makes sense because the iphone has a
smallest front uh sensor that's where
everything's in focus whereas that has
the most blur because this is using the
rear camera as well but not in a tough
lighting situation oh that looks nice
the one on the right immediately to me
this is a tough one they are all very
similar but i'm going to go with the one
on the left because of how sharp her
face and hair is i also think it's
really interesting this bar in the front
how like big and blurry it is while
these it's like so kind of sharp oh wow
yeah and all of these were with three
times zoom but the iphone seems to zoom
more like this other one seemed like
fake three times i don't know how to say
it yeah we got another shot here back
lit against the sun it's flaring the
lens as well this is a hard one you guys
keep saying that these are hard ones
which is a good thing because all of
these cameras are good are doing a
really good job i think i'm leaning more
towards the one on the right yeah me too
i like to i like how uh the face looks
more natural in terms of the colors and
stuff yeah there's a lot of detail too
looks like a dslr shot the most like it
s22
ultra
whoa
wow it's almost like there's three
different sunsets
yeah wow
i'm gonna go with the
left i like how the sunset is really
glowing the other two they're not
glowing blue even these trees look blue
it's like the highlights are cut down to
a certain level of like grayness where
this has aspects of really bright
glowing
uh colors and also i like the overall
color and detail everywhere
iphone ones to me it was interesting
that the older samsung s2 ultra
completely got rid of this color this
has a little bit yeah but that one's
just crazy
so obviously this is a selfie shot with
all the cameras in the center failed
yeah it's like super great it's so weird
to me how different each of these are
i'm gonna go with the one on the right i
feel like it's the most natural because
if you look on the left it feels like
there's just
over sharpening everywhere in his shirt
and his hair yeah and this is already
starting to get dark uh you know very
end of sunset
and we have one for the iphone is that
the first selfie at one i'm not sure
maybe
oh that's cool i mean this is easy
look at that that is awesome yeah the
one on the left looks amazing you got
glow from the sunset everywhere yeah you
guys probably already know what that one
is from the previous shots but
iphone again looks really right it
started getting catching up that's
really good as it gets dark so it looks
like uh just the dynamic range in some
of these shots
with the main camera at least you know
looks great
well man why is that left one so blue
and purple everywhere the trees is all
gray blue yeah and maybe we're living in
another planet i've got to go with the
center i love all the glow the sunset i
like how it brought up the
the plans
i'm very surprised how the z fold on a
lot of these hard shots is doing better
than s22 ultra yeah um both samsung same
tuning but it's just doing a better job
consistently okay we got a night shot
here this one really chooses to bring
everything up a lot to me this is easy
it's easily the one on the right because
everything pops out separately you know
here everything kind of blends in it's
the same kind of contrast levels
the lamp is nice and clean
yeah i don't like how this one brings it
up so much to where you can't tell if
it's day or night yeah it's definitely
not flaring is
true i love hearing your opinions you
guys notice stuff uh that i'm not even
seeing at first so good job so both for
the right yeah yeah
s22 ultra hey it's redeeming itself from
those other shots now this is getting
really dark
whoa whoa
frittles this place was super blue like
it commands attention when you're
driving by so i had to pull over i mean
i love the one in the center i love how
it's a little bit dark but like the glow
of the
neon sign just looks so nice and clean
s22 interesting and this is an ultra
wide shot here wow cause i literally
it's a sidewalk in a street of crazy
traffic so really nice we have this
inside shot very low lighting here it
was very dark i'm gonna choose the one
in the center because i like how it's
brought up and it's nice and bright it's
also the most detailed out of all of
them yeah now that i'm looking at like
these
stickers or whatever they definitely do
look like there's a lot more detail than
on the left one and the the right one is
just so dark
iphone iphone yeah it's interesting how
it's brought everything up so much
brighter brighter than in real life but
it is the shot that i think looks best
too we got a nighttime it's really dark
portrait shot on all of them this the
left one is so flat she completely
blends in with the back i would say for
me the one on the right is the most
clean because the one in the center
you're getting some like uh haze or
glare i think i'm actually to go with
the center despite that i feel like her
face looks a lot more natural when this
one is just a little too shadowy for me
see 2 4 samsung
0 for iphone yeah that one looks no
pretty bad
this is a nighttime shot with a bunch of
different lights different colors
okay what i don't like
is you have all this very strong
reflections from the uh it's like very
you know i think we already know what
that is already we have experience yeah
annoying uh feature
yep and i do know that i'm choosing the
one on the right okay yeah i don't like
how this one looks a little too over
sharpened
well this one looks not okay this is
pretty flat too
s twenty wow
and it's interesting how this is has
terrible reflections
this has some but you don't notice it
much and the fold has the very least
they're so subtle but this is just
this is an ultra wide uh there are a few
uh relatives hiding in the shop wait
what wait more you didn't see it oh i
was distracted by how dark everything
here is like what is happening
yep that is true spot a spot in elon
yeah i see him up there yeah this is
easy for me man this is easy what are
you choosing right the one on the left
is super soft everywhere right the one
on the right it gets way too dark back
there this is all right
yeah the one in the center is the best
balance z 2 4 samsung again so even the
ultra ride on the z fold is doing great
oh
what is that
whoa
this is uh i don't know what cinderella
cinderella rapunzel whose tower is it i
don't know
a potato
okay which which uh potato can did it
best i mean this is garbage this is
straight trash
look it looks like it's 8-bit bro
it's like 8-bit i mean obviously this
one has the most detail but yeah well i
mean i like
the thing is that
i don't know i mean the tower looks the
best however everything is destroyed you
can't even tell where this is what's
going on to see a tower here you
actually can tell that hey there's some
trees there's some cars there's some
stuff going on they're right i think yep
s22
one
what happened with the z phone man
my guess is that the z-fold probably
used the main sensor for this 10 times
crop and that's why it just looks so
terrible the iphone had probably used a
3x but it's very dark with that lens
interesting um it has more detail than
this 10x lens that's because this 10x
lens also doesn't do great at night
all of them kind of suck and we have
this shot of noah
left yeah i'm also gonna go with the
left um
i don't like any of them really yeah uh
the one on the right i like how his face
looks here but it's just too dark like a
shirt everything's too dark and you have
all the artifacts and everything here
there's no detail the one in the center
is way too flat
so left i think is the best i think the
left does the best in terms of like
detail with his face and hair if i could
take this and plop it onto that because
the whole background everything else
looks the most natural we need to do we
need multiple phones in our pockets and
photoshopping
s22
got the point i think the iphone
probably still using a three times lens
which is why it's like we have more
compression the colors but the low light
it's pretty terrible this is an ultra
wide very dark outside beautiful spokane
one of our best features well i don't
like the one on the right it's really
flat it's really gray
a lot less detail i see a lot more
detail i think on the left but i like
the colors and the balance in the center
one yeah i'm gonna go with the center as
well uh it looks the most natural clean
uh warm lights the one on the left has
tons of uh
artifacts and just blotchiness in the
sky especially and all the lights are
just smeared i don't know these lights
look smeared well there is a little bit
of glare but that's something the best
tail here i don't know i'm gonna say
left you go left left and center
we have z fold and iphone so it seems
like the iphone has just been doing
great with colors yeah even at night or
the day or at sunset it gets the colors
right and kind of true to it this was
super dark uh this is with the main lens
doing
some astro
photography
or attempting to we don't have any
pixels here we probably would know what
the results would be with the pixel but
that's in the next video that is in the
next video i have to say left yep i
agree this is horrible and this is
also horrible yeah so this one's
terrible it's all smeared and blurry and
between these two i looked at this
little area here it's definitely more oh
yeah so that's how you can easily tell
grass it doesn't look like grass at all
let's shoot left
s22 ultra yeah the iphone here was a 30
seconds which is the max it will do
but i think the clouds are just moving
too much and it created this
kind of
cool effect
but yeah these did a quicker shot
and our last shot
whoa
this is like no light i mean center it's
got to be the sun do you go with the one
that's the most bright or the most like
detailed
oh i mean look at this dude it looks
like crap
look at all the artifacts here and like
it just you can't even tell what's going
on
here you're like hey i see a grill
another grill and a light if you swipe
and you see this photo you just keep
swiping
[Laughter]
which one is the worst one that one on
the right
there you go s22 is the worst iphone is
the brightest so it can do a great job
when it's crazy
most of these night mode shots that i
mentioned in the previous one too the
iphone will do like one or two seconds
whereas the other ones will do four
seconds five seconds six seconds but
when it gets crazy dark the iphone will
decide to like hey let's bump it up we
need it and you get a result like that
so there you guys go hopefully that you
guys enjoyed it and that was fun uh go
ahead and comment down below let us know
what you voted for uh what scores you
got or at least if you didn't do that
what surprised you the most between the
differences between these phones and how
do you think the z-fold did did it do
better than you expected all right guys
okay
you go first you go first
what'd you get
well for me the s22 won with 15
followed by the fold with eleven and
then iphone with nine
iphone last iphone lost iphone i also
got nine for the iphone so it lost by
fart however for the brand new fold i
got 13. okay okay somebody did the math
quick for the s22 i got 13. there's a
tie
tie between the two samsung's that's
crazy an iphone got a tie with nine nine
nine uh with it losing
yeah so i think it's the only thing that
the iphone's still good at is some of
the colors and maybe portraits sometimes
because of colors yeah other than that
it is worse in every way 12 megapixels
again samsung's 12 megapixels again
we'll see what happens it's gonna change
with these new iphone 14s come out i
can't believe how good the fold is i
can't believe it what kind of sorcery
did samsung do this year i know a lot of
people including myself after the
announcement i was disappointed it's
almost the same thing but after using it
we test it out in our previous
comparison if you guys didn't see that
we will link in the description and at
the end check out the hands-on
comparison it did great and obviously
the cameras hold their own now and it's
too grand and it's too great
but you get under display camera too
come on no
it's very expensive obviously there's a
lot of cost going into doing these
multiple screens
and all that stuff but before the
cameras were a downside you spent two
grand the cameras would be noticeably
worse than you know spending half that
but now you're spending two grand at
least you know that you don't have sucky
cameras yes not really a sacrifice yeah
so we're also going to be doing the flip
against the iphone 13 and the pixel 6a
none of those have telephone telephoto
cameras so if you guys want to see that
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button above check out one of those
great videos right over there and we
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]